مثل ليوناردو فريزر الآمن إلى حد كبير ،
يُظهر لـ CNN الجهاز البسيط المظهر الذي
أحدث كل الاختلاف بالنسبة له ، فأنت
تتخلص من معصميك هنا ، إنه
جهاز مراقبة الإصبع يقيس
قلب الأكسجين والدم لدى Frazier الذي ارتداه البالغ من العمر 54 عامًا
في المنزل وحده بينما كان
يكافح فيروس كورونا  كان متصلاً
بهاتفه الخلوي وعندما تراجعت
حالته فجأة سمح
لأطبائه في شمال شرق أوهايو بمعرفة
وأخبرني أنني بحاجة إلى أن أكون
في غرفة الطوارئ على الفور ،
وهذا ما فعلته
يقول فرايزر إنه  شعرت بالعجز الشديد في
المنزل وحده لدرجة أنه لا يعرف ما إذا كان
لديه ما يكفي لإيصال نفسه
إلى المستشفى وهذا هنا
أنقذ حياتي وهذا هو سبب وجودي هنا
اليوم
ولكن حالة فريزر هي حالة نادرة حدث
لها  أن يتم وضعك في برنامج تجريبي في
مستشفيات الجامعة في أوهايو مصمم
للمساعدة في إنقاذ حياة المرضى الذين
يكافحون فيروس كورونا من المنزل حيث
يقول الخبراء إن حالة الضحايا يمكن
أن تنهار في لحظة غير مسبوقة  يمكن التنبؤ به
وبالتالي سيعود بعض المرضى إلى منازلهم وسيظلون بصحة
جيدة وستتحسن رئاتهم ،
وقد يتدهور الآخرون ، ولا
نعرف من سيتدهور وغالبًا ما يتدهورون
ويموتون في المنزل دون أن يعرف أحد
المسؤولين في المناطق الأكثر تضررًا.
تكافح الليلة لإحصاء
الأشخاص المعزولين بالفيروس في
المنزل وأعداد الأشخاص الذين
يعتقدون أنهم يموتون في المنزل ، كما يقولون ، إنه
مذهل ، قال عضو مجلس مدينة نيويورك مارك
ليفين الذي يرأس لجنة الصحة بالمدينة
قبل الوباء من 20 إلى
25 شخصًا  توفي في المنزل في نيويورك في
يوم عادي ، لكن في الأيام الأخيرة ،
يقول ليفين إن أكثر من 200
شخص يموتون في المنزل يوميًا نفترض أن
معظم هذه الزيادة ترجع إلى فيروس كورونا
حتى مع تكثيف خبراء الاختبار يقولون إن
أعداد
قد يكون عدد الذين ماتوا بسبب فيروس كورونا أقل من اللازم
عندما يقال ويفعل كل شيء بسبب
الثغرات الهائلة في مراقبة أولئك الذين
ماتوا في المنزل على ما أعتقد خلال هذه
الفترة الحادة من الوقت حيث كان هناك الكثير من الأشخاص.  لا
يحصل الناس على الرعاية الطبية ، فالناس
الذين يموتون في المنزل ، والأرقام التي
تتحدث عنها ،
بالتأكيد أعتقد أن المكان الملزم
خلال هذه الفترة الزمنية
يتدافع مسؤولو ولاية نيويورك الآن
لمحاولة سد تلك الثغرات في المعلومات
ابتكار طرق لحساب
الوفيات المحتملة بسبب فيروس كورونا ، بما في ذلك الضحايا الذين
لم يتم اختبارهم من قبل وأولئك الذين
يموتون في المنزل
والذين تتناسب أعراضهم مع معايير معينة
للفيروس ، وهو أمر مروّع ،
لكن الأرقام التي تتحدث عن نفسها
قد تجاوزت هذا الأمر مع زملائنا في مجال الصحة.
شيء نادر جدًا في مدينة نيويورك
وفجأة قفز إلى أعلى من الواضح أن
الشيء الوحيد الذي تغير هو kovat 19
لكن الخبراء يقولون إنه حتى مع اختبار ما بعد الوفاة ، فإن
الحصول على إحصاء دقيق حقًا
لأعداد الأشخاص الذين ماتوا بسبب
فيروس كورونا في المنزل قد  كن شبه
مستحيل أخبرنا أحد الأطباء أن هناك
فئة أخرى من الأشخاص يمكن
إدراجهم في عدد ضحايا هذا
الوباء  أولئك الذين ماتوا في المنزل من
أشياء مثل السكتات القلبية والسكتات الدماغية
والأمراض الأخرى الذين رفضوا الذهاب إلى
المستشفى خوفًا من أنهم قد يصابون
بذئب فيروس كورونا